The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Morning everyone.
I hope you all had a
great spring break.
And during which I hope
you can have more of 6.046.
Today we're going to look at
network flow and two things
in network flow.
The first one is
Edmonds-Karp algorithm,
and after that, we're going
to look at two applications.
In particular, they are called
bipartite matching and cover.
OK.
So we'll start with
a simpler algorithm,
which is Ford-Fulkerson.
Can someone remind us
what Ford-Fulkerson does?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Every time you
have a augmenting path,
it gets rid of it.
PROFESSOR: It gets rid of it?
Yep.
What's your name, by the way?
AUDIENCE: Michelle.
PROFESSOR: Michelle.
OK.
So, Michelle gave a
very brief description.
But let's be a little
bit more detailed.
So we have a graph
network flow G,
and the first thing it's going
to do is that given the flow,
it will transform G
from a residual graph.
Everyone remembers that?
Then F-F algorithm will find
a path going from source
to sink in this residual graph,
and then augment this path.
Augmenting just means increasing
the flow on that path.
By how much?
AUDIENCE: The minimum edge
on the path [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
minimum edge on the path.
Let me just define that to be
the capacity of the path, which
is the capacity of
the weakest link.
OK.
Then what's the last
step we're missing here?
So after augmenting, our flow
changed from f to f prime.
And then we're
going to look back.
We have f prime, then Gf
prime, find a path in Gf prime,
then continue from there.
So this algorithm,
in some sense,
is not even a very
detailed algorithm,
because it doesn't say how to
find a path in the second step.
And that's indeed a
problem, because we
have seen a pathologically bad
case where each capacity is
a billion, and the correct way
to do it is simply augmenting
this path and then
that path-- oh sorry,
there's edge one--
then we'll be done.
But the pathologically
bad case is we keep
going through this middle edge.
OK.
So Edmonds-Karp is an
improvement to this algorithm.
Let me just write it here.
Its first step, third,
and fourth steps
are actually exactly the same.
No change from Ford-Fulkerson.
The only thing it does is
that it finds a special path.
Did Srini cover
this in the lecture?
What path Edmonds-Karp finds?
I see some people nodding.
OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: He ran the first
search from the source
to the sink in Gf,
take the shortest path.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Does everyone agree with that?
So Edmonds-Karp finds
the shortest path.
From-- I guess, can
you see that part?
No?
Oh, I'm sorry about that.
Find the shortest path.
Here, shortest just means
least number of hops.
Here, in this
pathologically bad example,
Edmonds-Karp would
do much better,
because it would find this path,
instead of this weird path.
Because that path,
its distance is 2,
and the one going
across the middle is 3.
OK.
Now we're going to prove that
this algorithm runs in order
VE squared.
So OK.
So one step back.
Do we have to prove
that is correct?
That it indeed finds
the maximum flow?
AUDIENCE: No, you don't.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I claim I don't have to
do that, because it's
the same thing as
Ford-Fulkerson.
You can find any path.
Now, we want to show-- we
want to bound this run time.
So any idea, high-level idea,
how we're going to do that?
In which several steps?
OK.
So, OK, a simpler question.
What's the complexity of this
second step, find the shortest
path from source to sink?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: OV plus E.
PROFESSOR: OV plus
E. And in this case,
actually, V is always less than
E, so I can simply say O of E.
Now, how long does it
take to augment that path,
if we have found it?
AUDIENCE: O of E.
PROFESSOR: O of
E. That's correct.
But our claim, we can
also say it's O of V,
because the shortest path
at most has three hops.
And then, from f
to f prime-- OK.
So I think in some sense,
these two are the same steps.
Also O of V, and then
updating the rescue graph
is also O of V. So one
of these iterations--
each iteration takes how long?
AUDIENCE: O of E.
PROFESSOR: O of E. Right.
This is the most expensive
step in one iteration.
OK.
So what else do we have
to do to prove this bound?
AUDIENCE: Number of iterations.
PROFESSOR: We need to show
that the number of iterations
is O of V times E.
If we can show that,
then we are pretty much done.
OK?
OK.
Now, to prove that
bound, we first
need a lemma, which
we call monotonic.
So let me define delta f v. This
is the length of the shortest
path from s, from
the source, to v,
which is a node in a
graph, the length of that
in rescue graph of f.
Is that definition clear?
And this lemma says delta
f v, for any vertex v,
does not decrease.
So it can only
monotonically increase.
OK.
We are going to prove that.
So we'll prove by contradiction.
Assume this is not a case.
That means there is some
v that in f prime, which
is the new residual
graph, its shortest
path from the source in
the new residual graph
is less than the old one.
Right?
We are going to derive
a contradiction to that.
So there may be many
such vertices that drop.
But if there's any,
I'm going to define v
to be the one with
smallest delta in f prime.
OK.
Any questions about this step?
So there could be like v1, v2,
v3-- that all make this happen.
I'm going to choose
the one among those
that has the smallest
distance from the source.
OK?
Now here is my source.
We have a path to v
in graph Gf prime.
OK.
So this is a path.
Then I can always
find a predecessor,
which I'll call u here.
If this is the
shortest path to v,
what can I say about
delta of v and delta of u?
What can I say about
these two quantities?
AUDIENCE: Can v decrease?
Can v decrease one
of them, at least?
PROFESSOR: This one
is greater than that?
AUDIENCE: One of them must be--
PROFESSOR: One of them is
greater than the other,
and that's always true, right?
For any two?
AUDIENCE: v is u plus 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Michelle said v is u plus 1.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
That's the shortest path
to v. It goes through u.
OK.
That's correct.
So OK, maybe I wasn't
clear about that.
I defined u to be v's
predecessor on the shortest
path.
OK?
Then definitely delta f prime
of v is delta f prime u plus 1.
Now, I'll use u to
be my step stone
back to the original graph, f.
I want to say something
about this quantity and delta
u in graph f.
What can I say about that?
This is a tricky part.
AUDIENCE: It's greater than v?
PROFESSOR: This one
is greater than that?
Or the entire thing
OK.
I'm going to claim this one is
greater than delta f u plus 1.
By which I'm claiming this
quantity is larger than that.
Can anyone give a reason
why I can claim that?
So recall how I defined v.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
how you defined v?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
So v-- so there are several,
probably several v's that
have delta f prime
less than delta f.
I'm going to define v to be
the one with smallest delta f.
Among all those nodes that have
a job in delta f, in delta.
This is probably a tricky part.
Then by definition, since delta
f u is less than delta f v,
right, and I defined v to
be the one with the smallest
delta that satisfies that.
So all the u's-- so u
is a predecessor of v,
so u shouldn't be one of
those nodes that have a drop
in delta.
So I know this is
probably a tricky part.
Yeah, I'll stop for
questions and make
sure we resolve this
part before we move on.
How many people get it?
OK.
Only two.
That's not good.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm
confused about how v
can be the one with
the smallest delta f
if you have a predecessor
with a smaller delta f.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So v to be the smallest--
the one with smallest
f such that delta f prime
is less than delta f.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK, maybe, yeah,
that's why I confused you guys.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
So we have a bunch of nodes
who have a drop in delta,
and I defined v to be
the one among them that
has the smallest delta f prime.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I'm
lost at what delta
f prime is versus delta.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Delta f of a node
is the shortest path
from source to that
node in G of f,
which is the residual
graph given a flow.
So f is, well, some
flow, and f prime
is the flow after we
augmenting a certain path.
So f prime is one step after f.
OK.
How many people get that now?
Still not everyone.
OK.
Any questions about that?
How many people still
haven't got that?
OK, so some people-- it's
like Schrodinger's cat.
It's in the middle state.
Well, then I'll have
to move on, and I'll
assume you all get that one.
As the last step, so
of course we will ask,
what's the relation between
this guy and delta f of v?
Because in the end, we want
to show a contradiction
that delta f v is
probably greater or equal
to delta f of v. OK.
This is another tricky part.
So let me ask maybe a
simpler question now.
So that is our G of f prime.
So we also have G of f.
It has the source, some u
here, v there, sink there.
Does this edge
exist in this graph?
So I know if that edge
exists, because I defined u
to be the predecessor
of v. But u,
v is in that graph doesn't
necessarily mean u,
v is in the old graph.
It could certainly
exist, but is it possible
that this edge didn't exist?
How many people would say
that edge definitely exists?
maybe it doesn't exist?
OK.
It doesn't matter, because
we can prove both cases.
So let's say case
one, u, v is indeed
in the original graph, G of f.
OK.
In that case, can I say
something about that last step?
AUDIENCE: It's greater
or equal to delta f v.
PROFESSOR: Greater or
equal to delta v. OK.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because v was
on the shortest path.
Well-- yeah.
So the shortest path, either
passed through-- yeah.
The shortest path to v either
passed through u or didn't.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Does everyone get that?
So the shortest path
in this graph to v
is not necessarily
this one, right?
But if it's some other
one-- OK, so, in case one
I'm assuming this
edge exists, right?
Then no matter what
the shortest path
is, it's definitely shorter
than I first go to-- from s to u
and then u to v. Right?
The shortest path between s
to v is definitely shorter
than I first go from s to u
and then u to v. Make sense?
OK.
So case one, then,
is a contradiction,
because we showed that
delta f prime of v
is greater or equal to delta f
of v. Any questions about that?
OK.
Case two, u, v is not in Gf.
OK, so, how can
that even happen?
Is it possible that
this edge didn't exist?
AUDIENCE: It could be
a backwards-facing edge
that you add [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Great point.
That's exactly right.
So it is possible that this edge
didn't exist, but only appeared
after we go from f to f prime.
How can that happen?
That must mean we are
augmenting a path that
goes right through it.
Right?
But this edge doesn't exist, so
we cannot be augmenting a path
that crosses this way.
We must be augmenting a
path that goes like that.
First from s to v, and then
v to u, and then u to t.
If we are augmenting
such a path,
then we're going to remove
this edge from v to u,
but we will add u to
v to the next graph.
OK?
Did everyone get that?
So now, here--
well, formally I'm
going to claim if we assume
u, v is not in G of f,
and we also know u,
v is in Gf prime.
What does that mean?
These two can only
be caused by the fact
that u, v is in G of f.
Not only in that graph--
it must be on the path
we are augmenting.
Make sense?
OK.
So given that, can we say
something about delta f
of u and delta f of v?
So here is our p.
Right?
This entire thing here.
And p is the augmenting path.
AUDIENCE: And f u
is just f v plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Right.
So if that is the augmenting
path in Edmonds-Karp,
we are looking for
the shortest path.
Right?
So v is the predecessor
of u, then delta of u
is delta of v plus 1.
That means that quantity,
here, is delta f of v plus 2.
OK?
So it's also a contradiction
to what we assumed.
OK.
So that proves our
lemma of every node's
delta monotonically increases.
Now here, I'm going to show
that-- our final theorem,
that we have at most VE
number of iterations.
So the way we're going
to show that is we
are going to define a
capacity of the path.
It must be the capacity
of its weakest link.
We're going to define its
weakest link is u, v. OK?
And we're going to
show that u, v--
we'll call that critical
edge-- we're going to show u,
v can be critical
only O of V times.
If that holds for
every edge, then I
claim all the edges
combined can only
be augmented O of VE times.
Now, how do we show that?
So again, let's assume
we are augmenting
a path that goes
through u to v. If we
do that, by our algorithm,
we will get rid of this path,
and have an edge backwards.
We go from f to
some other f prime.
Now, when can I
augment u, v again?
It can only happen
if at some point,
I come back to augment the path
going from v to u, because that
will eliminate this back
edge, and and adds back
our edge u, v. OK.
Let's see what happens there.
Now I'll call this graph
f, this graph f prime.
So in f prime, we know we are
augmenting the path from v
to u.
Right.
The same argument, delta u,
is delta v plus 1 in f prime.
Correct?
And we know this one
doesn't drop, right?
So it's greater or equal
than delta f of v plus 1.
OK?
And we also know in f, v
is the predecessor of u.
So this one is equal
to delta f of u plus 2.
What does that mean?
It means in between two times
u, v is augmented, delta of u
must increase by at least 2.
Then how large can delta of
a certain node possibly be?
It's definitely
bounded by v. So then I
claim this particular edge,
u, v, can only be involved,
can only be critical
edge, O of V times.
Actually, half of V times.
Strictly.
So then, every edge
combined, there
can only be half of V times
E number of augmentations.
OK.
Any questions about that part?
About the entire proof?
If not, we'll move on.
OK.
This is not part of the
required in the recitation,
but I'll quickly say a few words
about an even better algorithm,
Dinic, which was in O
of V squared times E.
So this is an improvement
to Edmonds-Karp,
and its idea is that I'm
going to find all the shortest
paths in one go from s to t.
I'm going to augment all
of them at the same time.
Then, because they are all
shortest paths, when I augment
that, each path will be broken.
Maybe I'll get rid of this
edge, this edge, and that edge.
And the thesis is that the
shortest path will increase.
So here, the shortest
path is 3, but I
have destroyed all the
shortest path of length 3,
so I'm going to
shortest path of 4.
If they do that, you can
bound the number of iterations
to O of V, because your
shortest path can be,
at most, V. But each iteration
is slightly more complicated,
because you need to find
all the shortest paths,
and it happens that
they can show-- you
can find it in V times E.
That gives the V square of E.
That's not the important part.
The more interesting
part is that, actually,
the author of this algorithm,
his name is Dinitz.
But his algorithm is
very hard to understand.
Yeah, nobody got that.
And there's some other guy
whose name I think is Even.
He understood the problem and
started advertising to people
and giving lectures
on Dinitz's algorithm.
So he popularized the
algorithm, but unfortunately he
got the name of
the author wrong.
So that's why this
algorithm is henceforth
called Dinic's algorithm.
This is useful to know.
Why?
Because you can tell this story
to other people so they will
assume that you know a lot
about Dinic's algorithm,
while in fact, you
probably don't.
And that's exactly
what I'm doing here.
OK.
Now let's look at
one application.
Bipartite matching.
OK.
So the problem is that
we have several person
and several tasks.
And let me get
rid of one person,
because I don't want to
draw that many stuff.
So we have a graph like that.
And each edge-- if
there is an edge, that
means this person is capable
of performing that task.
And the problem is that--
find the matching, which
means the assignment
from people to tasks,
such that we get as many
tasks done as possible.
OK?
So one person can
only do one task,
and one task only
needs one person.
So here you can see
a bad matching, which
is I assign this
first guy to task one,
then no one can do task two.
So if I'm smarter, I'll assign
one of these guys to that task
and have this person
handle the other task.
Is the problem clear?
So this is called bipartite
graph, because-- well,
which means you can partition
a graph into two parts,
and within each part,
there's no edge connecting
any pair of vertices.
And you can also define this
problem for a general graph.
The goal is the same.
Find a subset of edges
such that no two edges are
connected to the same vertex.
But we are going to
look at bipartite graph.
And we claim in
bipartite graph, this
can be solved using max flow.
OK.
I'll give you one minute
to think about that, how
to transform that problem
to a max flow problem.
Any ideas?
OK.
A hint.
I will add the source
here, and the sink there,
and I'll have
created these edges.
OK.
How do I restrict the
capacity of all the edges
such that I can guarantee no
person is taking two tasks,
and no task is
assigned to two people?
AUDIENCE: Make all
of them weight 1.
PROFESSOR: Make all
OK.
You're right.
We do that-- 1, 1, 1, 1,
1, and everything here
is weight 1, then that's
definitely correct.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Calvin.
PROFESSOR: Calvin?
OK.
If we do that, then, well,
because each person only
has one incoming edge--
oh, sorry, maybe I
should have drawn
the arrows here.
Each person only has
one incoming edge,
so it cannot take care of
two tasks at the same time.
Right?
Same thing for each task.
It only has one outgoing edge,
so it cannot be taken care
of by multiple people.
OK.
So if we find--
if the max flow is
k, that means we can find
the max matching is also k.
We can get k tasks done.
It's very easy to see because
we can have a cut here,
and if the max flow is
k, that clearly k tasks
are taken care of.
OK.
Any questions about that?
AUDIENCE: So, the
question is can we do
all the assignment [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Find an assignment
from people to tasks
to get as many tasks
done as possible.
So how many tasks can we handle?
OK.
So I'm doing a different topic
from the recitation notes.
In the recitation notes, we
are considering another problem
called bipartite cover, which is
exactly the same thing as that.
So cover, also,
bipartite graph, is
defined too as, let's find
several vertices in this graph
such that each
node, at least-- OK,
let me color several
nodes in this graph-- such
that each edge is connected
to at least one dark node.
OK.
And this, the nodes I
colored, is called a cover.
I want to find a minimum cover.
You can of course cover all the
nodes, that trivially holds,
but we are looking
for the minimum cover.
And the claim is that min
cover is k if and only
if max flow-- sorry,
max matching-- is k.
Why is that?
Because in that matching--
if we have a matching,
then we have a set of
disjointed edges, right?
No two edges are connected
to the same node.
So if we want to
cover these edges,
we at least have to add
one of these guys-- color
one of these two,
and one of these two.
Right?
So if we have k matching
edges, then we at least
need k nodes to cover them.
For example, I can
cover them like that.
But this is not
foolproof, because I also
need to show I can indeed
find a cover that is k.
OK.
Let me think about whether
I should prove that.
OK.
I'm going to give it a try.
If you don't get
that, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Can you say
again what cover is?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cover--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Cover is
a set of nodes such
that every edge in the graph
is connected to at least one
of the nodes, in a cover.
OK?
So this is not a cover, because
this edge is not covered.
So in this case I probably
have to add that as well.
But clearly there's a better
cover, even a smaller cover,
which is those two.
Right?
Yeah.
So how are we going to transform
that matching to cover?
So let me first give
a matching here.
One max matching should
be something like this.
I have this edge and
one of those two.
That is a matching.
Right?
That is a max matching.
No questions about that?
Let me get rid of all this.
One way to transform
this into a cover
is that I will first
color these two guys.
I colored the nodes on
the left where they are
connected to a matching edge.
After that, I'm going
to start from this one
and jump between nodes,
taking an alternating path.
Meaning I'll take
an unmatched edge,
and then take a matched edge,
and then take an unmatched edge
again, but there's
no such thing.
OK.
And if I take this jump, I
will swap them, make that dark.
OK.
This graph is a little strange.
Ah, OK.
Now I claim this is a cover.
Is that?
Yeah, that is one, right?
And if there is another
unmatched edge going out,
then I'll keep taking
that alternating path.
But I have to stop, because
there's no such edge anymore.
How can I say-- why
I can prove-- why can
I claim this is a cover?
So clearly if this is a cover,
then it's a cover of size k,
right?
So we have proved
the entire thing.
Then we're going to consider
several things separately.
So I'm going to first claim
if I have a matched edge,
then it's definitely covered,
because one of its end points
is dark.
Right.
We only do a switching
between dark and white
if it's a matched edge itself.
Right.
So I only need to show that
this thing doesn't happen.
There's an edge
that's unmatched,
and two of its endpoints
are both white.
OK.
I'm going to first claim this
node cannot have a matched
edge.
Because if it does, then
this is an alternating path,
and I'm going to
switch this too.
OK.
Make sense?
So this doesn't exist.
So it can only have
an unmatched edge.
Now what can I say
about this node?
I claim this node needs at least
one matched edge, because if it
doesn't, right, then I should
add this guy into my matching.
It doesn't violate
any constraint.
I didn't add that because
there's probably a matched
edge connecting to this guy.
Then I'm going to--
so, then this guy
has to be dark, because
this one is not.
Then how did this
one become dark?
It must have come from some
other guy on the left, right?
So there's an alternating
path going back and forth.
Something like this.
There is an alternating
path, starting from left,
but ends here.
Because we showed that
this guy is not connecting
to any matched edges.
In that case, what I'm going
to do is match this edge,
match this edge,
then unmatch these two edges.
And that's a larger matching.
Because I removed the
two, I added three.
That means a max matching of k
leads to a minimum cover of k
as well, which also means max
flow of k in our network flow.
So this part-- this
equivalence is not required.
You should know this proof,
the proof of Edmonds-Karp,
and know that a
matching and cover can
be solved by network flow,
and that Dinitz's name is
spelled not as Dinic.
OK.
And that's everything for today.